it looks like the name of the next
destiny expansion has been leaked I'm
Dave and welcome to your loot hoarding
news update Bungie space shooter destiny
is getting a new expansion and according
to a leaked online it will be called
rise of iron as reported by Kotaku via
reddit a photo was posted online of a
poster the revealed a new expansions
title ketaki alleges that two sources
familiar with bungie have confirmed the
posters authenticity the rise of iron
expansion will reportedly feature a new
raid and will be larger than both year
one dlc packs the character featured in
the image is wielding a hammer which
would suggest a new type of weapon will
be introduced as part of the expansion
in February activision announced a large
new expansions scheduled to release for
destiny this year the news is revealed
alongside the announcement of a destiny
sequel which will be launching in 2017
destiny has three expansions thus far
dark below house of wolves and the taken
King with the game recently celebrating
hitting 30 million registered players so
we use still running raids in the world
of destiny would another expansion get
you back into the fray let us know in
the comments section below or find me on
Twitter at a regular Dave and for your
gaming news stay tuned to gamespot com